a new app called spreadsheets is it's
tracking your performance between the
sheets yeah basically using users
movement and audio levels it tracks how
long and the duration that you're having
sex I guess how long in duration at the
same thing so these are the states with
the longest duration of sex New Mexico
they are doing it seven minutes and one
second long of sex West Virginia Idaho
South Carolina Missouri Michigan Utah
Oregon Nebraska and Alabama so the tent
there's a four minute duration Bay
there's basically a three and a half
four minute difference between one and
ten in the length of sex and these are
the states with the shortest duration of
sex Louisiana Kentucky Arkansas DC
Nevada Georgia Montana Vermont South
Dakota and Alaska they are only having
now this is self-reported of course and
you have to have the app for this but
one minute and 21 seconds worth of sex
do these numbers make any sense to you
well New Mexico is supposed to be I've
never been there but I heard it's just
beautiful so seven minutes it would be
like seven minutes in heaven with the
mountains and the sky wonderful no
there's no state that has sex for six
minutes like two five that six minutes
is it's in the nether there's no six of
the devil's but one minute Alaska one
minute and 21 seconds it's because it's
so cold so okay I just want to get it
over with
you see but I thought it was the reverse
in Alaska it seems like you would want
the body warmth just to avoid the
hypothermia wouldn't you be having more
sex they might have sex 15 times in a
row
Oh each instance last one minute
twenty-one seconds I think there's a
reporting error perhaps yeah 15 is a bit
excessive
[Music]
cell phone worked
scientific cuz you basically have to
have an iPhone in the app and you have
to be willing to record yourself and all
that kind of stuff one minute twenty one
seconds those people seem great at sex
there's no efficient these people in
like alright honey whatever I do I put
it again huh I just I moved from
Massachusetts to California yeah I
gained seven seconds in the bedroom yeah
and do you feel your sex life is better
here in California I was in
Massachusetts I have no idea what I
think it's really interesting
I wondered if those numbers included
foreplay or if that was just oh that is
a good question yeah you were thinking
the same thing I was wondering like once
you start going where is there chocolate
my husband cleaning up I think that
extra seven seconds of me getting the
towel by the way we should tell you guys
that New York is ranked 23rd at 301 and
California at 238 they're ranked 32nd
where really though where does this fall
into your sex these all these numbers
seem incredibly low to me
seven minutes that's the longest I mean
seven minutes for me you know that would
be very very short
[Applause]
how long you've been in a relationship
because like I feel like any second
spend spent trying to have sex with my
girlfriend is me inconveniencing her and
at this point if she's like let's go
visit people in Alaska let's just get
you over with as fast as possible yeah
that's your code Alaska yeah hurry it up
yeah where do you want to go tonight
sweetheart Alaska or near Alaska yeah
now where do you I believe are the one
married panelist Here I am
how does sex how does that fit into the
married life is it like I've got to do
this because we have to do this a
certain amount of time per week but I
could be more loaded cause I would much
rather get a massage man you add the
massage at almost 53 what how do i I
don't know it's a very personal very um
but let's just say seven minutes is I
guess that's average that average but as
you said Brett it depends on how many
times yeah yeah
so I like to think this is not very
popular app so maybe the white person
who has this app in New Mexico just
takes longer than the one person who has
this map like there is like someone
who's like in their 30s in New Mexico
who has it doesn't really finish as fast
as they used to and then there's like a
19 year old in Alaska who's like I'm
finished already let's move on yeah
[Music]